[Music]  tucked away in the depths of Siberia is  the town of Mira knee a cityscape  dominated by a massive hole in the  ground  [Music]  this open pit was once a thriving  diamond mine me Ernie was one of the  first places diamonds were found in  Russia Lemire mine is about 1700 feet  deep and is one of the largest mines in  the world while the mine is now closed  it stands as a testament to the small  towns perseverance against the harsh  Siberian winters building the mind was a  difficult task it took seven years of  miners battling winters for seven months  out of the year  with temperatures hitting below freezing  digging was nearly impossible in the  frozen ground with this historic  landmark the small towns record-breaking  mined reminds its inhabitants that they  are still a diamond in the rough  [Music]